we are in the Honda Suns and
columnist in her new show tiny beautiful
things my new favorite show and she's
about to Dole out some advice to our
audience members our first question is
from Kendall hello Kendall what's your
question okay so hi Catherine hi candle
my name is Kendall um I've been dating
my boyfriend for four years now and he
continues to post like the ugliest most
embarrassing pictures of me so my
question is how do I get him to post
cute pictures where I look pretty so
what's your advice for me okay have you
asked him to stop yes I have okay well
then
I don't understand why he would be why
he would go against your desires is my
question his on his defense he likes to
tell me I still look beautiful in those
pictures oh well then you can honestly
say to him that you don't feel beautiful
and it makes you feel uncomfortable but
I think it's funny like yeah he thinks
too though maybe you gotta post some of
him
oh
yeah
turn it into a funny game that's the
best advice ever again Kendall all right
our next question is from Tatiana and
her girlfriend she Kayla what is your
crack question for Catherine Han all
right so my girlfriend can be really
messy she'll put items in different
areas of the house as you can see on
their work desk the closets random
drawers and so basically I need some
help on how can I get her to stop
putting random things in areas we don't
know or can't find hey all right listen
I'm in a very similar situation where I
am a real I really love a neat space but
my husband doesn't care as much and so
there's a some training involved
but B you gotta really also just
allow for and compromise
and maybe give each other their own your
own spaces that can be one can be messy
and one can be clean and my husband is
going to play this back to me when I
give him crap
that's right for his stuff it's the high
road advice and I really needed to hear
it I hope that it helps you guys
it's not impossible all right our last
question is one from an old co-star of
yours oh who is it um
[Music]
miss you hey so when we work together on
Parks and Rec I was just blown away with
your knowledge and your wisdom and now
you're playing a character with
knowledge and wisdom on your show I
could use
um some advice
I'm doing a show called unstable
currently in Netflix with my son
and he's a bill what do you do when
you're working with your kid on a show
and he's just up ill any advice you have
would really be appreciated no
okay well listen the I think that the
chances of you working on a show with
your kid are one in a gazillion who gets
to do that like I mean my I mean I have
a 16 year old who's basically like I'm
like do you want to text it Friday at
what like nobody wants to hang so you
what that you definitely want to spend
as much time with your kid as you can
well I would love one last piece of
advice from you because I have nine and
ten-year-olds anything of a piece of
wisdom to drop for me well I mean I I'm
definitely in the middle of it I was
talking with my friend we were 35 when
we first had an iPhone in our hands so
like it's crazy to think that these kids
already have that so I when I can try to
and also just to continually remind her
that that is not reality in any way and
um to Foster Real intimate one-on-one
connections with actual human beings and
friends you know what I mean like you
you want to be
that is such good advice and I love you
so much
[Applause]
Tatiana you guys are segmented for you
spring cleaning tips
[Music]
foreign